All right,
so let's get this
show on the road.
Welcome, everybody, to the
speedrun game.   Last couple
of games have been really instructive,
like, really
instructive. So we're riding a pretty good
streak. Um, those watching on YouTube,
welcome to you as well. I want
to thank everybody who subscribes and
supports the channel. We're very close to
300K subs,   which
is a big milestone for me. So the
best way to support the channel, if you like
the content and you like what I do, is
just to hit the subscribe button. All right,
we're playing in
1140 with the white pieces
and we continue   to play
my sort of official opening
recommendations, and we are facing the
French defense. Okay?   So
those of you who've watched my
Speedrun more assiduously, you will
probably remember what my
official recommendation is against the
French. And this is
a very dangerous line
that hits,  uh, a
couple of different,    uh,
targets at once. On the one hand, it's
very dangerous from a theoretical
standpoint. If black is not careful, then
white can get a big objective advantage. But
this line also teaches you a lot
about closed structures
and a lot about positional chests in
general. So it's always good to have a line
like this in your pocket that basically
forces you to display your knowledge,
uh, of certain typical
structures and certain,   uh, important
positional ideas. And the line that I'm
alluding to is not the Tarash, which I
play at my level. I play the move Nike D
Two, but a line that I have
also played over the board. And I think the
official name for it is the Nimsovich
French. It starts just
like an advanced French. We start by
playing the Move E five. This is the
advance, and Black
responds with C five. So this is standard
fare. And here the Move, which
is almost automatic for most
people, is, of course, to support the pawn
chain by pushing C three. And that
leads to   very, uh,  theoretical waters.
The advanced French is a
totally viable weapon and it's gained a
lot of popularity in recent years, so even
at super high level. But
the line that has slipped through the cracks
is actually to play this
without C three and instead
to develop your pieces as if nothing is the
matter. So the nimsovich
French goes knight to
f three. We simply develop our knight
and we allow black   to ruin
our pawn chain by playing
C takes D Four.
So you can go back through
the first speedrun and look at
a couple of games in which I played this
line. I will do a quick overview
of the basic ideas. Once again, in case this
is the first time that you're seeing the
Move Night F three. If it is the first time
you're seeing night F three, then you should
be very, very surprised because it seems
utterly counterintuitive,
uh, to allow
the pawn chain to be destroyed. Let
alone to sacrifice the pawn on D
four, which is what we're going to do. And
here we continue playing as
though Black is not exerting any pressure
on D four. We continue developing our
pieces. Now, people who are less
experienced in the French, one common
mistake that I see players making   is that
they play no, not bishop B six, but
bishop B five in this position
is a very common move. At the beginner
level, that is not a good move. The Bishop
on B five is not
futile, and it's not bad because it
loses a piece. It doesn't lose a piece.
Queen a five check. There is knight C.
Three.   So it's bad from a
conceptual standpoint, the Bishop on B five
is a total paper tiger, and Blackenge just
block the pin with bishop D seven. So
the best square in such
positions for white's Bishop, and
we're going to deploy the bishop to that
square right now is actually D
three. And there's many
reasons for that. Anytime you have, you
know, a pawn on D four like this, putting
the Bishop behind the pawn is good practice
in case Black castle's
Kingside, which is the likeliest
direction that Black will eventually castle,
we will have a Greek gift sacrifice at the
ready. But I hear the thought that's on your
mind, doesn't Black just have C four pushing
the Bishop back to E two? Well,
they do, but we have
provoked C four, and because the center
is relatively closed, we can
afford in such positions to make
more than one move with the same piece.
So what is White achieved
by provoking the move C
four? Well, a couple of very
specific things. First of all, we've
taken a lot of the pressure off of the
D four pawn. We no longer have to worry
about our pawn chain getting destroyed. So
we can instead focus on more important
things like quickly
completing our Kingside development.
Now, Black's pawn
chain on the Queen side might seem very
imposing, and the move B five is actually
good, but in fact, Black has bitten off a
lot more than she can
chew,  okay? And the
reason for that is that Black is pushing all
of their pawns on the Queen's side without
supporting them with his or
her pieces. And what we can do
is use our pawns in a kind
of very typical idea
to break down the entire
pawn chain. The Black is building up on the
Queenside. And the way that we do that is by
putting pressure simultaneously on
both the C four pawn
as well as the B five pawn. And we have
both pawns that can do that. We play
the move B three, setting
up pressure on the C four pawn, and we
follow up with the move A four. A
very, very important motif.
This is kind of classic pawn play
to break down Black's pawn chain
as quickly as possible. And we can
do it without delay. We can castle
we can take a move and complete our
Kingside development, but we don't even need
to do that. We can just straight up play a
four in this position. And Black is
already under very
serious fire on the Queenside.
And one important tactical detail that you
should notice is that A six is futile
here because of A takes B five.
And Black cannot recapture with the A pawn
because the rook on a eight hangs. So that's
part of the reason it's important to do this
in timely fashion. If we had allowed Black
to play the move bishop to B seven,
which is not played to develop the Bishop to
an active square, it's played in order to
defend the rook. A four, while
still a pretty decent move,
is a lot less effective on account of
a six, that move is now possible.
So here this is rather time
sensitive. And with the rook on a eight
undefended, a four is a very powerful
move.   Bishop a six. So
our opponent,
conceptually, is playing reasonably.
Uh,   he or she is trying
to protect the pawn
chain with, uh, the pieces,
with the minor pieces. But it's not going
to work because the minor pieces are just
not very good at keeping
the pawn chain intact.
And even though Black is going to avoid
losing pawns immediately, we're still going
to break up the pawn chain. So which pawn
should we take first? Well,
normally, we should begin by
eliminating the base of the pawn chain.
Step one is to play
A takes B five, eliminating
the kind of linchpin on B
five. Now, step two
would, of course, be to then take the pawn
on C four, opening up the center
and creating a major
weakness on C four as a result.
Now, we can also kind of
ignore the situation, and we can just
castle but far more to
the point and far more kind
of consecutive is to play the move B takes
C four. And as a result of the trade,
black is going to get a massive
weakness on C four. Bishop
takes c four. And now, of course, we
complete the trade with Bishop takes C four.
And after D take C four,
we have achieved precisely
what we said about to do on the Queen side.
We have created long
term permanent weaknesses on the
queenside. What are those
weaknesses? Well, the main weakness is this
pawn on C four. And step three
is going to involve two
kind of mini steps we need to complete our
development. It's going to be hard for us to
operate to our full capacity without
castling and without solidifying
our own pawn chain. How are we going to
solidify our pawn chain? What move comes to
mind here as kind of an automatic
move? If you're a French player with
White,   what is kind of the general,
solidifying move that we're going to play at
some point yeah, that's the move c three.
Now, you might say, well, wait a second.
Isn't the C three square? Shouldn't that be
reserved for the knight? No, the knight
doesn't go to C three in such positions.
It's going to go out to D two. Because,
remember, the ultimate idea, uh,
is to harass and ultimately win the C
four pawn. So what's going
to be the order of operations here? Well, we
can do things in a bunch of different
orders. I like the idea. What appeals to
me is just castling
kingside first, just to get the king out
of the danger zone, make sure that there
are no nasty checks on B
four. Then after that, to play the
move C three. And only
after those two preliminary steps are
complete can we go
about the process of
surrounding and winning the C four
pawn. So castling first is
safe, because Black has no good way to
attack the D four pawn. Rook D
eight is a very likely move at this
level. And just in time,
we follow up with the move C three.
Notice also in that position,
that knight takes e five is not
possible because the knight on F three
guards the e five font. So our opponent is
trying to open up the center,
which is a counterproductive idea
because Black is lacking in development.
And this is an important moment
for me to highlight the idea of flexibility.
Right. We created
this entire elaborate
scheme where we were going to go C
three, and then we were going to go night
BD two. But Black's
last move has changed absolutely
everything. F six is a huge move, and
we need to, uh, understand how that
impacts our course of action. Well, it
changes our course of action entirely
because Black is inviting us to open up
the center. Now, who benefits in the event
that the center opens up? Well, the side
that's better developed in the side with
less pawn weaknesses. And clearly,
in both cases, that's white. So
we should actually welcome the
opening of the center, and
we should do that just by taking on, um, F
six and saying, you want to open up the
center? Thank you very much. I'm going to
open up the center. And, um, more precisely,
I'm going to open up the e file on which
sits a massive pawn weakness on e
six. Now, combining the two
previous observations, right, there are two
big weaknesses in Black's camp the pawn on
E six, the newly created weakness.
But nothing happened to the old weakness
of C four. So putting those
two things together generates for us
the move queen to e two, hitting both
of these pawns at once. That's the classy
move.   Now, a
good alternative to queen e two would be the
simple rookie one. We could say, hey, I
don't care about the C four pawn. What I
care about more is the pawn on e six. That's
the juicy pond. If we win that pawn,
we're probably going to checkmate black in a
matter of a couple of moves.
Furthermore, after queen e two, as, uh, some
of you are astutely pointing out, there's
the nasty move. Knight takes d four,
and that leads to a
slightly complicated line. Knight takes d
four. Knight takes d four. Queen takes d
four. We grabbed a pawn on e six with
check. Black plays bishop e
seven, and I'm not
entirely sold on the fact
that white has a crystal clear
way to capitalize on the attack
there. So a more
controlled move in this position
would just be to play the move rookie one,
leaving the queen on a defensive spot for
now, to guard the d four pawn.
And it's incredibly hard for black to
defend upon an e six. That is a huge
weakness. And Black's lack of
development is really costing her
here, as you can see, because if
black had already developed the
bishop on f eight, then they
would be able to castle Kingside,
and we would still take the pawn on e six,
but black would get a pretty major
lead in development in that case. Now
Black just doesn't have the time
to complete the development. King f seven is
an attempt to defend
the pawn on e six, but it's futile.
The king is not a good defender in these
kinds of positions. How should we
proceed in this position?
How should we proceed in this position?
Yeah, there is a rip move, and of course,
that move is the simple fork on g
five,   knocking the king back to
g eight. The game is not over.
The game is far from over. We won a
pawn, but we still need to
demonstrate some good technique,
especially considering the fact that we have
not completed our queen. We haven't even
started our queensight development, so
we're going to have to play this accurately
if we want to win the game fast.
Okay, so I'm, um,   anticipating king
to g eight here. Our opponent is playing
very fast,    and
that's a risky thing to do in a
position with a king this wide
open. King e seven. Whoa.
Okay. Our opponent just walks
right into the pin. That's a
terrible move,   but how do we
punish it in the most clinical
way? What's the order of operations
here? Well, you might be tempted here by the
move knight takes e six to set up a
potential discovery. Knight takes c six is
okay, but it gives black a new
lease on life. Knight takes e six, allows
the king to step away from the
discovery with king f seven and then go back
to g eight. A much better
approach here would be to take on e
six with the rook, but not because it's a
check. Right. The fact that it's a check is
a nice byproduct. What I'm noticing here
is that there's a pin against the
knight on uh, C six. So on
the next move, we can actually pre move D
five. And that ends the game on the spot
because it wins the night on C six. And once
the minor piece is gone, the black king is
also getting hunted down mercilessly here.
So D five is the game winning move.
And we're going to win this game, really,
without our entire queenside. We won't
even need most probably our
night on B one and bishop on C one. That's
how powerful our existing
pieces are.   Yeah, it's a
little bit too late to start thinking, but
you do often see this at this level
where people kind of rattle off these
opening moves, and then by the time it's
too late, they start thinking,
yeah, the game is totally over.
We're taking the night on the next move, the
knight cannot move because the queen is
pinned. And it's going to be checkmate in
three moves here. It's going to be checkmate
in three moves. Who can give me the
entire checkmating line from start to
finish? And if you're watching on YouTube,
try to generate that line as well.
It's a simple mating line,
but it's always good practice to try
to visualize these lines in your mind.
It really gets the wheels turning
without moving the queen, not DC. And Queen
d seven. The D seven square is protected by
the knight on F six. DC.
Is correct.    And then the
next move is Washington. Now
just getting after DC. King c seven.
What's the mating move?
I never said there's a
moratorium on bringing the queen's side
pieces out. Bishop F four is the mating
move. Very good. DC. Check. The knight
defends the rook, which is very important.
And after king C seven, the mating move
is bishop F four. Technically black as
bishop D six. That's why it's made in three.
And Queen takes d six. There is checkmate.
Simple, straightforward attacking chest,
bringing the bishop out with a
devastating check and ending
the game on the spot.
Yeah, straightforward game.
And you can see the
power of   the line that
we played in the French. It's an incredibly
powerful line   at, uh,
any level, I would say
2300 and under.
So let's quickly go over the game.
Um, we
played     the line
that I have played previously in The
Speedrun, and this is what I have played,
uh, almost exclusively when we faced
the French in all of across all of the speed
runs I've had thus far. So E
five   is the advanced French,
but now we deviate from standard
waters with the move night F three.
And night F three has kind of an
interesting history. This move has been
around for a very long time. And Aaron
Nimzovic, who I'm sure most people watching
have heard of, he is, of course, one
of the kind of patriarchal figures
of modern positional chess. He wrote a very
famous book called My System in the
1920s, which kind of laid out a
lot of the positional concepts that we now
take for granted. I mean, he was the
originator of overprotection and
prophylaxis, and he talked about square
control and trades.
When he released my system, all of these
concepts were not in the common
chest vocabulary. So people were
reading that book with their mouth kind of
open, like, oh, my God, this is amazing.
Now, Night f three was first
played in the year let me check.
It was first played in the year
by an unknown player. And
Nimzovich was maybe the 7th or the 8th
guy to play night f three, but he was
playing it religiously. Nimzovich faced the
French a lot, and he played knight f three
exclusively. So it was pretty impressive to
generate this idea in the early 19
hundreds. And most of Nimzovich's
opponents actually did not
play C takes D four.
So after C takes
d four, nimzovich was the
first player to realize
that the best move in this position
is not knight takes D four. This just
defeats the purpose of the line. Does that
make sense? Night takes d four
is not where the party's at black and
just go, night C six. And this
begs the question, well, why on earth
didn't you play C three if this is how you
want to play? Instead, white needs to
aim for very rapid development. What is
the actual move after C takes D four? Who
can tell me?    No, it's not
queen takes D four that walks
into knight C six. Even more blatantly.
It's bishop d three. Good memory. Bishop d
three. And the basic
idea of this line, according to Nimzovich,
is that the pawn on e five is
there's no name for this pawn, but it's like
a clamp pawn. It clamps
down very effectively on black's
position, severing the connection
between the queen side and the kingside,
making it difficult for black to get her
pieces out effectively.
In particular, it
prevents knight f six. It prevents
bishop d six, and it
makes it very difficult for black to
breathe. And white is going to accelerate
his his kingside development
as much as possible. So, for example, if
black just develops normally, let's say
knight C six, and we have faced this in the
Speedrun White Castles,
and already you can see how difficult it
is for black to develop comfortably.
So if black
plays, let's say, bishop C five, we are not
trying to win the pawn back quickly.
We're trying to win it back eventually.
And the way that we're going to do that is
by putting the B one knight on what square.
Who can tell me what square the knight
on B one usually belongs on in this line.
So it goes to d two. But what's
the final destination?
Very good. The knight belongs on this very
nice B three square,
where it's out of the way of the bishops.
It's not obstructing the bishops that's
important. And it's obviously
putting pressure on the D four pawn. So
eventually we're going to win the pawn back.
Black drops the bishop back to B six.
And one great thing about this line is that
it gives you a chance to carry out the Greek
gift sacrifice. A ton of people end up
castling here and this loses the game
on the spot to a classic
instance of the Greek gift. Bishop h
seven night. G five. Check. And you know the
drill. King G six, queen G four, et
cetera. So you can definitely
win your fair share of games
in this line with a Greek gift sacrifice.
Now, obviously, Black does not need to fall
for the Greek gift. And if we go
back to this position, which is actually
in my analysis, this is a legitimate
theoretical position in this line, the way
the black can avoid the Greek gift is either
by delaying castling, black can play bishop
d seven, or black can
situate a knight on g six and
prevent the bishop from taking on h seven.
But at this point, white can already win the
pawn back. And after bishop G six,
HG night,   uh, I think the move here
is actually to throw in H
three to, uh, take the sting out
of queen H four. And
according to the engine, the engine
sometimes gives a small edge for White when
we're going to take back on D four, and
we're going to support the knight with C
three, and we're going to leave black with
this terrible French bishop on C eight.
So there's a lot of theory in this
line and black has many ways to
equalize, but nonetheless, there's a good
amount of meat on the bone in this
line.   Um, now,
I'm sure we're going to face the French
again, and we're going to face it at a
higher level. So remember, the kind of idea
of the speedrun is for me to introduce
opening ideas slowly. When we're at like
twelve to 1300, I'm talking more about
concepts, I'm talking about some basic
theory. And as we rise through the
ranks, I'll start talking more
specifically and give you actual lines
and actual analysis.   So
the basic idea of this line is to develop
your kingside very quickly and make sure
that whatever you do, you don't give up the
pawn on E five easily.
Now, at a high level, people
who understand the French understand that
one of Black's main weapons in these types
of positions is a, um, move like F, uh, six.
Black can try to physically get rid of the E
five pawn, but white's not
giving that pawn away easily. And
here, white has the very strong response,
bishop B five,   you might say. Well,
wait a second, didn't I mention earlier that
bishop B five is a
misplaced bishop in this line? Well, again,
the situation has changed completely
as a result of the move F six
and here. Bishop B five should make perfect
sense to you're. Taking the sting
out of FTAC C five. Now, Knight takes E
five is incredibly strong because you're
attacking from both sides. Queen H five is a
threat, and Knight takes C Six is a
threat. So Bishop B five is a
prophylactic measure against Ftec
five. Okay? So
F six is not a panacea either.
It's a risky move, and if Black
knows what what they're doing,   uh,
then he can get away with it. But
in any case, our
opponent took a different approach. Knight c
six. Bishop d three. And our opponent
decided not to take on D four at all, and
instead to push C four, which already
gives White a, uh, sizable
advantage after the move bishop E two.
This is already a
sizable advantage for White, according to
the engine. I've analyzed this line because
it's very, very common at the lower levels
to push C four. So
I think b five is a, uh, further
inaccuracy. I don't think it's a terrible
move, but I actually think Black's main
mistake,   uh, early in the opening was
this move, queen B six. I feel like after A
four, Black's Queenside is already
collapsing. And it would
not be too radical to say that Black is
borderline lost here. Like with the queen
side totally gone,
black's Kingside is undeveloped. It's
plus over minus at this point.
So I think the last chance for
Black to keep his queen side relatively
well protected was to play
what? Who can tell me a decent move for
Black here that allows them to
keep the queenside
more or less
defended?
And you might remember what I mentioned
about A four and why A four is so
strong in this position. Yeah, bishop B
seven, or maybe bishop D seven. The engine
likes putting the bishop on D seven, which
makes some sense. It's a little bit more
centralized than the bishop on B seven.
And after A four, Black plays a
six and Black holds on
the queen side is still
intact. And then Black will try to
get these Kingside pieces out. Nike
e seven. Night F five is a very typical
maneuver in the French. White is
better. And from White side,
I wouldn't even rush with a four.
White has this
interesting move in such positions to
actually just push the H pawn.
And your idea is to push
it all the way to H five and maybe
even to H six to provoke dark square
weaknesses on the Kingside.  And
the secondary idea is to prevent the Black
Knight from jumping into G six, which
is a super typical kind of parking spot in
these positions.  Furthermore, you also
take the sting out of the move knight F
five, because now the GPA comes
to the rescue with G four.
So, without the pawn on
H five, if you think about it,
let's make a couple of random moves.
Let's say White plays c three.
And White plays a developing move, and
black puts the net on F five. Here
the move. G. Four. And this is very common
in the French. You should remember this. G
four in this version is not
effective. Who can tell me why?
What does black have in
response to G four here   that
he wouldn't have had with the pawn already
on h five? Yeah, there is this very nasty
move night h four, and you've bitten
off more than you can chew on the king side
because after the trade,
you've got all of these weird kind of
weaknesses on the king side, you can't go
knight F three. This pawn is sticking out
like a sore thumb. Black can go H five
later. So compared
to the position   after
the pawn appears on h five here, after G
four, the rook controls H four. So the
knight is pushed back to E seven or back to
h six. So this is
why closed positions are difficult to
play, because they're all of these, like,
subtleties. And everything really
does boil down to
to, uh, nuances and to
to who can position their pieces better, who
understands more ideas about the position.
And, uh, this is a good example of
that. How does bishop D seven solve
the A takes B five? Weakness asks
taper knight. Well, it solves the problem
because after A four A six, the
queen and the rook are connected. So A takes
B five is no longer
effective. You're not losing the rook on
a eight. You can just recapture with the
queen.   And of course, with the bishop
still on C eight, the rook is unprotected.
So queen B six is a good move.
Conceptually. Our opponent
understood that he needs to protect the pawn
chain on the kings on the queen side,
but forgot, I would imagine, that
A six is no longer effective
with the rook on a eight. Unprotected.
Dark Tiger asks, was A
four B four, B three?
That's a mouthful, a valid
continuation. So I would say not as
much. And the reason why
consists in the move B four. The
presence of this move would make a four
futile. And now, if you were to play B
three after C three, black has
buried your entire queenside under a
pile of rubble. This is a nightmare scenario
because you're never getting your night out
without sacrificing it. This is what you
want to avoid. And I could show you
a bunch of games like this.
And if you play C three,
then black and again try to bury you
with the move B three, this is not quite as
disastrous, but clearly white
has not achieved, uh,  anything positive on
the queen side. Clearly, white has not
achieved anything positive. So in this case,
you actually want to fix the root of the
pawn chain first so that
black can't play B four or run
the risk of losing the C four pawn.
So in any case, queen B six, a four,
bishop A six. Now
we clear the shrubbery on the
queenside and we leave Black
with a massive pawn
weakness on C four, as well as a wide
open queen side that we can use to
infiltrate, uh, later on with the
move rook B one. So I think the
main theme of the middle game
was how we managed to switch
at the drop of a hat from one plan
to another, right? So our initial plan,
which we would have put into effect after a
move like rook D eight, was to first play C
three   and then play night
BD two and surround
the pawn on C four, which is really easy to
do because black can't defend this pawn.
If queen B five,
then the simplest move here, I think, is
just queen to e two.
And I should point out that black can try
to go knight D five and counterattack the
c three pawn. But here we can kind
of switch gears a little bit and go night
to e four.   Very
typical square in this particular type of
structure.   And there is
basically no rush to win the pawn on C
four. We can use the other knight
and drop it back to d two.
So notice how we apportion the rolls here.
The knight defends c three and contest the d
six square, while the other knight is going
to drop back and win the c four pawn. So
Black's not going to give away the pond that
easily. So if you play night ft two
here, black might go knight A
five.   But at this point, we
can clear off the d six square.
Another very typical idea in the
French bishop c one to a three.
Devastating move. Absolutely
devastating because after the
trade, 96 is a
totally unstoppable idea. Black's
also falling apart here on the queen side,
that knight on a five is very poorly
defended. White's going to go rook to b
one and dislodge the queen. This is
plus five already, so so it
gets bad really, really quickly. In any
case, our opponent goes f six and
we switch gears here. We just grab the pawn
on f six. Maybe not the best move,
but definitely the simplest approach to the
position. And we switch from attacking
the c four pawn to attacking
the more relevant weakness, which
is of course, e six because that's the pawn
which is standing between our pieces and
Black's king. Now, king f seven
is clearly a decisive mistake.
And after ni g five, check, king e seven
loses immediately. It accelerates the
process. King g eight would have allowed
black to stay in the game for a bit
longer here. We would have taken on e six
with the knight. And on the next move, we
can switch back to our old idea. We
can go queen e two and win the pawn
on C four. So this is
obviously a totally
indefensible position for black. It's around
plus four.   But
perhaps black can hold on here.
I don't know. The engines
suggest h five. That tells you all you need
to know about this position. Rick Gava
asks, could we go queeny two instead
of rookie one? Absolutely. And
I even pointed this out. The reason I
rejected queeny two is because I didn't want
to deal with the complications after night
64. And to
reiterate the line that I presented during
the game, this position I was not entirely
sure how to evaluate. Because as
winning as it looks for white, there is only
one piece in the attack. It's the queen. So,
with the engine on, I see that white is, in
fact, completely winning, but not with
queen c six. Check. This would be a very
hasty move.
Notice that after king f seven, the rooks
are connected, and white loses the attack.
The move is actually just rookie one. Simple
chess attack. The bishop on e
seven   force the black queen
to return to d seven. And what has been the
consequence of that? Well, now the c four
pawn is finally unprotected. We could
grab it, and on the next
move, bishop a three is going to
create devastating threats against
blacks. Bishop on e seven.
Okay.    Um,   and
notice that black also can't castle. That's
a very important function of keeping
the queen on this diagonal.    So,
in any case, this was winning. But
we decided to play it even simpler with
rookie one. Perhaps black should have played
a move like 98 to at
least try to cling to this pawn on e six.
But my idea here was just to go c three
and revert back to our initial idea.
Bishop b seven. Just go night BD two. At
least here, black and castle. And the game
continues. At least here, the game
continues. But with an extra pawn, black's
position is in shambles. The pawn on e six
is a terrible weakness. We've got
a beautiful pawn chain on the queen side.
This is around plus three, so the game goes
on. But white is obviously, technically
winning. So a simple
game,   nothing special. But
nonetheless, I think a good illustration of
basic ideas and I'm not commentating
past this point. This is all very
obvious. I think a good illustration
of    nice, uh,
play with a close center,
typical ideas in the NIMS of
its French, which is the first time that
we faced the french, was this game.
And takeaways involve
ideas of attacking what may seem
to be an imposing pawn chain on the queen
side. So it's not always about how
much space your opponent controls. It's
also about how well defended the pawn chain
is. And you can use your pawns, in many
cases, to    what I would call
clear the straubbery, just, like, blast
through,    uh, what seems
to be an imposing pawn chain. And as a
consequence of that, you often leave your
opponent with just a jumble of weaknesses
that you can then attack. And the most
common way of doing that is by pushing
B three and then pushing A four. And
very importantly, if you're on the black
side of a position like this, make sure that
the rook on A eight is protected so that you
can push a six and at least support
the pun on B five.   All
right? So that's what I'll say,
folks. I would get another game in,
but, um, I think it's getting pretty late.
I have lost in a speedrun, but it's only
been to cheaters.